can you summarize
for our viewers the impact of omicron in
your country thus far how many infected
how many hospitalizations um and how
many deaths
yeah good morning uh trevor
yeah i think it's been a kind of a mixed
bag in a way because basically on the
one hand we've had a very rapid rising
uh rate of infections in fact if you
look at the epidemic epidemic curve it's
almost vertical
so steep as it's going up in fact our
doubling time at the moment
is uh about one to one point five days
it's in other words every one and a half
days we're doubling in numbers so it's
it's rapidly increasing that's on the
one hand
on the other hand our hospitalization
rates have not been that high uh and
also within hospitalized uh within
hospitalized individuals uh it's only
about 15 percent i think is the latest
deity we've got
of those hospitalized are actually
either in icu or in high care so it
looks so far that the
the clinical expression has been mild
but that could really be
due to the fact that immunity in the
country is high either from natural
immunity or past infection uh or from
the uh from vaccinations so that's the
other so that's the kind of positive
side the rate of transmission is the
negative side um and the one other
negative that does appear to be quite
quite apparent
is that there's a lot of what we call
vaccine escape a lot of people that have
been fully vaccinated are still getting
infected but fortunately of that group
the great majority are mild so that's a
kind of a round
overall picture where we are at the
moment
that's very helpful um
the population of south africa is
on average much younger than the
population here and our
cabinet minister secretary of state for
education who i spoke to earlier in the
program
painted a picture of exponential growth
of omicron here which
at one level is pretty terrifying and he
said that even if it is milder as you
seem to be suggesting from the data in
south africa we could still end up with
a really large number of cases bearing
in mind
that uh we have you know many more older
people um is that something that we
ought to be alarmed about
you know actually i don't want to give
the the kind of wrong impression that
the omicron is causing milder disease i
think what we're seeing there's a lot
more about it but that's i think because
of immunity
uh it's very early days at this stage
and i don't think at this stage we can
be confident in saying omicron is a
milder variant we hope it's going to be
but i don't think we can say and you
know if you look at the virus itself
very logically to date there's no real
evidence to suggest that will be milder
so you make a very good point if there's
a higher proportion of older individuals
it may well not express itself quite as
much as we've seen quite in the same way
as you see in south africa but i must
what one thing i should point out though
is that we are seeing more and more
cases in younger individuals in fact
even young children as
young as two years of old age we've seen
quite some serious cases
so we need to kind of take that into the
balance as well
so would your advice to us be
don't get ahead of yourself
treat this as
being as serious potentially as delta or
any other variant we've encountered thus
far
i think we need to i think we need to
i think we must avoid trivializing it at
this stage we're still gathering
information we're hoping it's going to
be a time advice but we really cannot
say so at this stage so at the moment we
do need to treat it as seriously as
delta with all the kind of precautions
that we took for delta we can't let up
on that at the moment
have you got any thoughts or any idea
about how long before we'll get some
hard enough data to be able to make
you know proper
sense of how serious this thing really
is
yeah we were all we are gathering data
in fact day by day week by week
so i would guess that certainly in the
next couple of weeks which we should
have a much better uh perspective on the
virus uh we must remember we've only had
this virus for about three or four weeks
so it's still really early days
restaurant in south africa on the upward
trajectory of our fourth wave so we
still need to kind of be cautious
hopefully three or four weeks time we'll
have a much better view of it
so we may know something by the new year
um
our government is saying and i heard it
again this morning from from our
minister
that uh
there is evidence that
the
booster jab uh has
a significant impact on the virulence of
omicron is that what you're seeing in
south africa
yes i think the booster certainly will
will have a significant effect you know
it's only relative that there is vaccine
escape so obviously the more we
stimulate the immune system we can kind
of get a higher level of immunity to
overcome this potential vaccine escape
in south africa we're not we haven't yet
we're not nearly as extensive
in boosting
as you are for example the united
kingdom so we wouldn't really be able to
kind of give data at this stage on that
professor thank you so much for your
information valuable and
fascinating as ever
thank you trevor thank you